several house republicans are demanding
the removal of california democrat eric
swalwell
from the house intelligence committee
swahwell is under fire for his ties to a
woman accused
of being a chinese spy i think nancy
pelosi needs to explain to why she put
eric swalwell on the
house intelligence committee i believe
speaker pelosi has addressed this issue
she's got full confidence in
representative schwab we should always
be vigilant to
follow the code of ethics i don't know
any of the details of this case
no members should be surprised because
we've been briefed about this i think if
a republican
had been doing had done this swalwell
will be the first person to call for
them
to be booted from the intel committee
so far speaker pelosi has refused to
remove swalwell swalwell
cooperated with the fbi and was never
under investigation himself
the incident took place in 2015.
swalwell was on capitol hill today
told fox news he was willing to be
interviewed about his relationship with
the chinese woman
but shortly after voting he left the
capital in a hurry
all of this is the latest fallout in a
growing scandal of chinese espionage at
the highest levels of government and
business
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin reports tonight from the
pentagon
the fbi says it opens a new
counterintelligence case against
china every 10 hours beijing's goal to
steal u.s companies trade secrets and
americans data
the chinese communist party tries to
cultivate
americans at all levels of government
not just senators and congressmen
and not just democrats or republicans
but anyone who might be influential in
american politics in the future
secretary of state mike pompeo recently
warned wisconsin state
legislators they need to have their
guard up know
that when you're approached by a chinese
diplomat it is
likely not in the spirit of cooperation
or friendship
know that if you're offered a trip to
china when the pandemic travel
restrictions
restrictions are lifted that you should
ask who's paying for the trip
and if that person is linked directly or
indirectly to the chinese communist
party
the fbi director says out of 000 open
counterintelligence investigations half
involve the chinese communist government
we do not want to live in a world where
the chinese communist party sets the
rules that is going to be a world in
which
their massive individual surveillance
state is imposed on all of us
mobile cell phone networks used by
americans when they travel outside the
u.s are particularly vulnerable
a study at exigent media found china
conducting surveillance attacks against
u.s mobile phone users
over 3 and 4g networks american tourists
traveling in the caribbean did not
realize
that their cell phone signal was being
routed through chinese telecom operators
like unicom
when they visited barbados or the
bahamas cyber security experts who we
spoke to say this was likely part of a
state-sponsored espionage campaign
by beijing that affected tens of
thousands of americans in the past two
years
brett jennifer griffin live at the
pentagon jennifer thank you
fox news has just learned the 2020
intelligence community assessment
focused on foreign election influence
will be delayed
it comes amid a dispute between senior
intelligence analysts were told
over whether china sought to influence
last month's election
sources told fox news a number of senior
intelligence analysts are adamant
that china did try to interfere with the
election while a number of others are
downplaying china's activities either
way
because of that dispute they'll miss the
december 18th
deadline for that report